der alltag im weltraum ist ziemlich
unkomfortabel und ganz schön kompliziert
zu essen gibt es ausschließlich
gefriergetrocknete gerichte sich den
rücken zu kratzen ist schier unmöglich
und wie frustriert muss man bitte sein
wenn man gerade in den ausschüssen
braucht aber der kollege ihn an bord in
eine dunkle ecke der station hat
entscheiden lassen
die nasa tüftelt tatsächlich gerade an
der lösung für all diese probleme und
die heißt 3d druck im weltraum was genau
astronauten und astronautinnen bereits
im all gedruckt haben und ob demnächst
ganze mondstation 3d gedruckt werden
jetzt in kriegs und science fiction
herzlich willkommen ach ja und am
schluss habe ich noch ein geschenk für
euch wir alle wissen von urlaubsreisen
dass es super nervig ist wichtige dinge
zu hause vergessen zu haben
je nachdem wo wir im urlaub sind können
wir das dann aber am reiseort selbst
nachkaufen bei astronauten und
astronautinnen ist das anders wenn ihnen
dinge verloren gehen oder sachen im
weltraum ausgehen sieht sie zu 100
prozent abhängig von der nächsten
lieferung die sie von der erde erreicht
und das kann dauern mal eben schnell
shoppen im weltall ist eben nicht und
selbst die dinge die man mitnehmen darf
können an einer hand abgezählt werden
denn daran dass es extrem aufwändig ist
dinge ins all zu bringen hat sich nichts
geändert seitdem es die bemannte
raumfahrt überhaupt gibt je nachdem wie
weit die jeweilige mission von der erde
entfernt es ist es auch oft überhaupt
gar nicht möglich etwas nachzuliefern
teilweise mussten auch erst passende
transportmöglichkeiten geschaffen werden
da sind dann auch schon mal jahre bei
vergangen die nasa sucht händeringend
nach neuen lösungsansätzen für all diese
probleme und hier kamen die technik des
3d drucks ganz zurecht hier bei uns auf
der erde kann man mit hilfe von 3 d
drucker mittlerweile medizinischen
prothesen anfertigen und überhaupt die
kompliziertesten teile jeder art
nachbauen viele sagen der technik das
potenzial voraus ganze industriezweige
zu revolutionieren und auch im weltraum
eröffnet der 3d druck tatsächlich
unbegrenzte möglichkeiten es würde die
arbeit der astronauten unheimlich
erleichtern druck dateien könnten auf
der erde erstellt und per e mail an das
raumschiff gesendet werden kleine
satelliten komponenten könnten genauso
wie komplette experimente dann vor ort
gedruckt und die
direkt verwendet werden wow was für eine
vorstellung und tatsächlich arbeiten
weltraumbehörden weltweit daran um diese
idee zur realität werden zu lassen auf
der internationalen raumstation iss hat
einen 3d drucker auch schon seine erste
testphase erfolgreichen das ich gemacht
insgesamt 13 teile hat er produziert
unter anderem einen raatschen schlüssel
mehr als elf zentimeter lang innerhalb
von einer woche wurde er auf der erde
designt von der sicherheitsregeln der
nasa abgesegnet und ist dann zum ss
drucker geschickt worden um das werkzeug
in 3d zu drucken hat es nicht länger als
vier stunden gedauert wahnsinn wirklich
in gebrauch war der 3d schlüssel dann im
weltraum allerdings nicht denn die nasa
ingenieure haben andere dinge mit ihm
vor auf der erde wollen sie nun
erforschen wie sich die geschmolzenen
plastik tröpfchen in der
schwerelosigkeit zu objekt schichten
verbinden eindrucksvoll hätten die 13 0
gedruckten objekte gezeigt wie stabil
und filigranen dinge werden können die
in der schwerelosigkeit gedruckt worden
waren so die nasa wenn es gibt einen
großen unterschied zum 3d druck auf der
erde im weltraum übernimmt die
oberflächenspannung die aufgabe die
winzigen plastik tröpfchen an ort und
stelle zu halten
aus denen die gedruckten objekte am ende
bestehen dass er möglichst ganz andere
objekte zu drucken als hier auf der erde
denn hier geschieht das durch die
gravitation nicht nur die nasa sondern
auch die esa also die europäische
raumfahrtagentur plan große erfolge in
sachen 3d druck die unterkünfte für eine
geplante mondbasis sollen aus staub
gedruckt werden und auch wenn es völlig
abgefahren klingt diese pläne könnten
tatsächlich aufgehen
hoffnung macht ein erster versuch in
einem ingenieursteam eine 1,5 tonnen
schweren baustein hergestellt hat und
zwar aus basalt also vulkanischen
gestein das mondstaub zu 99,8 prozent
ähnlich ist und flüssiger tinte und auch
das essence probleme im weltall könnte
mit hilfe der 3d technik vergessen sein
die nasa konkurriert mit einem
dienstleister die grundelemente des
essens also proteine und kohlehydrate
beispielsweise in langlebiges pulver
zelle einen 3d drucker könnte das
lieblingsgericht der kuh dann auf einer
heißen platte schicht für schicht
anrichten
in ein paar jahren könnten es sich die
astronauten also eventuell
mit den entsprechenden aromen frisch
gedruckt schmecken lassen
eine rosige zukunft für den weltraum
vielen dank an technology review in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion ist
dieses video entstanden und exklusiv für
pixum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein
geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine
ausgabe dieser wirklich
außergewöhnlichen zeitschrift gratis
wenn ihr auf diesen link klingt es lohnt
sich wirklich und hier geht es weiter
mit virtual reality verändert die welt
genauso welt verändern wie 3d druck
klick drauf wenn es euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran